d te has hidratado hoy
cómo se sienten acerca de la cultura de
la persona de cancelación cancelación si
es o la cancelación es mala en mi
opinión no es algo que realmente esté
sucediendo si tuvieras que clasificar de
frente a otros en función de un rasgo
específico qué dirías sobre cómo los ves
y cómo te ven reunimos a cinco liberales
y les pedimos que se clasificarán de
menos a más políticamente de la
izquierda luego les pedimos que tomaron
la prueba de la brújula política y se
reorganizarán en función de qué tan de
izquierdas son en realidad esta es la
clasificación
mi nombre es max cumplí 24 hoy es mi
cumpleaños trabajo en la industria de
los videojuegos soy crisis y tengo 26
años trabajó ocasionalmente así que no
lo sé sólo soy una persona que vives hoy
jay el trabajo en educación sin fines de
lucro tengo 27
soy brandy tengo 30 y soy dueña de una
marca de bienestar y estilo de vida no
soy allison tengo 26 años y soy
escritora editora de anuncios puedo ser
directo que es lo que creo que contaría
como una persona de izquierda sin seguro
presionar por atención médica
y está para todos cosas así quiero que
esta persona tenga un salario digno que
viva cómodamente que simplemente viva si
tuviera algo que decirle a la gente en
general es luchar por los derechos de
los demás y por su comodidad asegúrate
de que los demás humanos sean humanos
para ti lo que yo priorizaría qué es lo
que alguien de afuera haría es la
vivienda justa porque si elegiste acceso
la mayoría de los problemas se
resolverán que estarías dispuesto a
perder porque sería una buena cantidad
de gasto militar por eso
todos radio los podemos estar de acuerdo
con zizou porque creo que hay personas
que son conservadoras tal vez no de
extrema derecha pero dirían que creen en
los derechos lgtb pero son fiscalmente
conservadoras soy profesional de lo que
sea pero si no estás invirtiendo dinero
no siento que realmente estás diciendo
que crecen así que opinan acerca del
conflicto palestino-israelí
si tienen alguna solución para el
conflicto alguna propuesta para
solucionar lo que dices no porque es muy
difícil pero sé que me importa un poco
más eso que lo de ucrania
qué es lo peor que he visto en los
últimos cinco años están todas las
banderas de ucrania en todas partes y
todos están dando el apoyo cuando el
conflicto entre palestina e israel ha
estado ocurriendo durante mucho más
tiempo cómo se sienten acerca de la
cultura de la pintura de cancelación
acción cancelación si algo así la
cancelación es falsa en mi opinión no es
algo que realmente esté sucediendo lo
voy a decir de el chapel day
después de ese último especial hubo una
parte en especial en que dijo oye solo
soy humano sigue pasando por una
experiencia creo que eso fue lo
principal que todos se perdieron cuando
estaba hablando de su amigo citado
correcto dice yo no soy una persona que
tiene la experiencia está colocando el
cojín hacia abajo hola chicos sé que me
van a golpear pero no me lastimen uno
pero eso es real aunque eso es algo real
tienen amigos que son de derechas y si
hay cosas que son una especie de factor
decisivo y por eso conozco gente si es
un factor decisivo entonces no no son
amigos y tengo amigos que están en el
lado derecho del espectro tengo primos
que puedo decir que son algo de hecho
converso de vez en cuando con ellos
sería genial llegar a un punto en el que
la derecha dijera oh vaya así que esta
gente está presionando por cosas que nos
afectan de una manera amistosa pero
crees que la gente piensa eso crees que
la gente de derecha piensa que todos
merecen un hogar o crees que sienten
quién trabaja en él y por supuesto que
no sus creencias son tan extremas que se
cruzan con una pregunta moral para mí de
quiénes son como personas cómo ven a
otras personas y no quiero interactuar
constantemente en una relación de
amistad con alguien que piensa así no lo
sé no creo que solo porque te etiquete
es políticamente de cierta manera no
puedas estar con personas que estén del
otro lado y no es que sean malas
personas pero los hay a veces pienso
sería mi amigo si yo fuera de cierto
color o de cierta religión le seguiría
gustando crecí en la iglesia yo estaba
en la banda de mi iglesia tuve varias
semanas en las que predique y luego un
día dije oh viejo esto apesta
estas personas tienen puntos de vista
que son anti humanos mientras que ellos
aquí predican amaos unos a otros estoy
como un dios a tu vecino ustedes son los
que me dicen que lo somos les merecen
arder en el infierno y perdí muchos
amigos cuando salí de eso fue más
personal o fue más político
probablemente sea más político mucha
gente que es más pro vida lo más normal
que podemos hacer es estar a favor del
derecho a decidir y dicen no algunas
mujeres tienen dificultades para ligarse
las trompas si no tienen hijos hacia el
médico decide que son demasiado están
veneradas no tienen hija es una decisión
de salud personal podríamos movernos
ahora si no se sentí que se trataba más
de intentar demostrar quién es el más
radical
creo que éste será mi lugar
entonces tendría que venir
aquí no sé es difícil porque parece que
todos estamos de acuerdo hasta cierto
punto por eso dios debemos hacer una
pregunta controversial pregunta
controversial qué piensas de la policía
creo que son un mal necesario creo que
las regulaciones importante pueden mover
ximamente el gremio de los policías es
uno de los más grandes y fuertes
son grandes y diría acá no sé si iría
tan lejos pero siguió en tomar parte de
su presupuesto y redistribuir los
servicios que ayuden a las personas el
hecho de que el departamento de policía
de nueva york sea el tamaño de un
ejército es aterrador y ves que muchas
cosas malas ocurren a partir de eso por
esa razón un paso más y eso es lo que
digo ok
ejército
me refiero de nuevo a un mal necio el
miembro ejército bien yo tengo amigos
que tuvieron que unirse al ejército por
razones económicas ya sabes el ejército
te enseña muchas cosas la disciplina eso
te en la vida civil sientes que hay un
problema mayor ahí que la gente tiene
que ir al ejército para hacer economía
funcionaría muy bien si estamos
asignando este dinero armas que no son
necesarias cosas locas no soy un gran
fan de los mil ok voy a cambiar metiste
a ese alguien genial bien creo que el
ejército en general 90 10 es mejor que
ninguno creo que es muy muy conservador
ser muy pro ejército eso es un cartel de
ideología conservadora soy bastante pro
ejército pero no lo sé no me apasiona
tanto entrar en la conversación que
están teniendo bien tengo una pregunta
sobre la diversidad representativa
muchas veces cuando hablamos de
diversidad y cosas así nunca es un
progresista siempre solo diversidad
basada en la apariencia a mí me importan
las políticas y él está representable
importarme menos quién es pero si los
polis definitivamente estoy a favor
necesitamos diversificar los modelos o
las personas que vemos en estas
industrias pero creo que debería ser más
quiero decir la equidad es el objetivo
si hiciéramos mejor trabajo al
identificar las diferencias entonces no
tendríamos tanto tiempo para compensarlo
la sociedad al tónica condujo a este
problema de bay que me parece muy
molesto en cada entrenamiento al que
tengo que ir alguien particularmente es
pro capitalismo o anti no me gusta ming
wang eres un poco anti estarían estaré
ante y quiero decir yo participo por qué
debo hacer creo que soy un poco más del
tipo capitalismo equitativo siento que
podríamos hacer el mejor capitalismo o
podríamos arreglar lo que eso es genial
es como el sujeto en seattle que perdió
su salario y también salario de todos a
71 mil 500 y si estamos en un mundo
donde las personas tienen yates y van al
espacio para divertirse mientras hay
personas muriendo en las calles y
hambrientas si puedes dar más creo que
podrías y deberías simplemente porque es
un grupo cuánto necesita realmente una
persona diría correcto pero el sistema
en el título nacimos en el que nacieron
nuestros padres todos optaron por el
sistema capitalista donde pensamos que
ganamos más dinero y que hay que ganar
más dinero y todo eso pero jeff bezos se
quedó con todo el dinero mientras se la
gane pero la cuestión es que todavía es
ilegal tomar su dinero
qué hay de esas personas no no a
nuestros políticos realmente no les
importa el bienestar de la clase
trabajadora el salario mínimo sigue
siendo muy bajo que estamos haciendo
supongo que aquí hay una pregunta
entonces quiero lo mejor para todos pero
eso también implica cierta
responsabilidad personal no quiero que
alguien simplemente obtenga mucho dinero
y luego no haga nada creo que es una
cosa muy inclinada a la izquierda pensar
en cómo todos deberían estar despiertos
trabajando y haciendo eso está bien
decirlo porque creo que todos
contribuyen para que la sociedad
funcione algo de lo que acabas de decir
siento que podría estar del otro lado en
ese tema la gente trabaja muy duro y no
es como si fuera un juego justo para
empezar así que seguro si las personas
no deberían quedarse sentadas y pueden
hacer otra cosa pero si no pueden
merecen comodidad y cameron lo que estén
haciendo mientras haga nada en algo pero
qué pasa si sólo quieres relajarte amigo
la vida es dura a veces puedes tener una
buena semana y no hacer nada o que haya
nada de malo en eso
[Música]
y ahora van a ir a política al compás
punto o hereje y hacen la prueba allí
[Música]
e
en el puesto número 5 allison
salida genial en el lugar número cuatro
tenemos a max sí
me sorprendió un poco que max estuviera
a mi lado simplemente me pareció alguien
que era más anti establecimiento sabes
anticapitalismo más anárquico ese tipo
de cosa esto fue en el lugar número 3
tenemos a chris o bien si
en el puesto número 2 tenemos a gay
bien
en el puesto número 1 tenemos a brandy
interesante no estábamos cerca dirige
creo firmemente que las cosas dependen
de mí y me inclinaré a la izquierda
porque me importa esperaba que ustedes
se eligieran a un conservador al azar
para que nos echaran pero igual fue
genial fue genial ver cuán similares nos
sentíamos en algunas cosas pero también
como definitivamente había cosas que se
desviaban más pero todos estábamos de
acuerdo en que todos somos liberales
honestamente pensé que tal vez estaría
en el terreno y pensé que iba a ascender
es difícil clasificar a la gente como
nosotros si me pregunto que elegí que
era más un pensamiento conservador
todavía estaba bastante a la izquierda
en esa brújula así que eso es una locura
es impresionante